in 2010 this man forrest fenn hit a
chest filled with gold and rare
artifacts somewhere in the rocky
mountains
the search for this million-dollar
treasure has obsessed thousands of
seekers worldwide
and the trail starts with this poem
which fenn wrote
it contains nine clues that point to the
treasure's location it's here someplace
we rolling
as i have gone alone in there and with
my treasures bowl
i can keep my secret where and hen of
rich is new and old
[Music]
fen's motivation for hiding the treasure
was to give hope to those knocked down
by the recession
and to inspire them to explore the wild
i found a beautiful little romanesque
treasure chest and i started filling it
up with with gold coins and gold nuggets
and about 280 rubies
there are two salon sapphires there are
eight emeralds a bunch of diamonds but
mostly gold
i don't know what it's worth and i don't
even want to think about that you're not
going to be disappointed if you find
that treasure chest
[Applause]
i'm cynthia meacham and i am a full-time
treasure hunter
i have been
looking for fenn's treasure now for a
little over three and a half years
i had the treasure chest more than 8.25
miles north of santa fe in the rocky
mountains someplace
nobody knows but me
[Music]
the poem that you have to solve forrest
always said you have to find where warm
waters halt and to me this is where our
warm waters halt
that's where i think that we need to
find the treasure chest
[Music]
the thrill of this chase for fenn's
treasure has led many to leave the
safety of known trails and well-beaten
paths
the mountains are very unforgiving
[Music]
it's extremely important that you know
what you're doing and you know where
you're going
you can end up in big trouble really
quickly
there's even one hiker that's been lost
looking for the treasure and he hasn't
been found yet
[Music]
to fen's knowledge the treasure remains
a hidden mystery
but the real reward should come from the
hunt
i was positive this was our warm waters
halt and unfortunately i just
i don't think that this is going to be
the spot
[Music]
it doesn't matter what state you
treasure hunt in you're going to have
beautiful scenery like this
and it doesn't matter if you find a
treasure chest or not this is finding
the treasure
right here
[Music]
so hear me all and listen good your
effort will be worth the coal
if you are brave and in the wood
i give you title to the gold
when i first started treasure hunting
i'll come down to the river pretty much
every single day and i'd surf and rap
and have a good time at the river
but the first time i went underneath the
water it just opened my eyes to a world
i didn't know existed
[Music]
my name is jay kohler i'm a free diver
and treasure hunter you guys ready
let's do it man
i dive in the chattahoochee river in
columbus georgia which is one of the
world's largest urban white water
courses ever built so this is actually
georgia and the other side of the river
is alabama
thousands of people go down this river
every single year and they lose all
kinds of valuables and it's a lot of fun
to go out there and swim and see if i
can find some stuff they lost
[Music]
some of the most interesting things i
found definitely have to be like iphones
gopros pistols
[Music]
always pretty interesting to find like a
potential murder weapon out here in a
river but gopros and phones definitely
my favorite finds
when i find these cameras and phones i
try to just figure out who it belongs to
because not only like finding this stuff
is a lot of fun but giving back the
devices that they've lost is also a
blast you got money be careful out here
i will
not only you find a lot of cool stuff
that people lose after rafting but
thousands upon thousands of fishermen
come up here and
normally no one would go out there and
collect all these fishing lures but i go
out there and i'll free them from the
wall and free them from the stumps and
it just kind of cleans up the area and i
get free fishing lures
there's a lot of animals underneath the
water you got a lot of striped bass shad
spotted bass and a catfish you see a lot
of turtles down here too it's just super
beautiful to see all that stuff
okay first thing back to jake finds a
gopro
he was diving right next to me i was
really surprised how many people were
interested in watching treasure hunting
videos someone said hey hey
we got another fan over there i guess
i love coming down here looking for
treasure and surfing and having a good
time but i didn't know i can actually do
this as like a full-time job i started
my youtube channel and record myself
swimming and having a good time at the
river and one thing led to another and
now i'm able to do this as i'm a
full-time job oh my god
oh it's going quick
two
[Applause]
[Music]
it more the more i travel the more i
realize that this spot is actually one
of a kind there's not many places in the
world that you can actually surf at a
river you know you could fish and
treasure hunt
i have a love for this river man and i
just can't stay inside i have to go down
and have a good time
[Music]
gilbert faku is a farmer his homeland is
remote near the bottom of africa
his life his wealth is in his farm and
the herd of cattley tens but what he
found in his backyard has brought him on
an extraordinary adventure
[Music]
[Music]
during the centuries of european
navigation toward the indian ocean ships
frequently passed gilbert's homeland on
south africa's eastern cape
one such trip ran aground leaving
countless spoils and gilbert is one of
the few who knows their location
[Music]
upon
[Music]
his fines are varied usually bits of
porcelain and beads but its most prized
possession is what keeps him coming back
and i've been doing a
teleport
it's a jewel encrusted pendant so
valuable yet he refuses to sell it
well for money that is
[Music]
hi
it's not very many people really know
but the great lakes has thousands of
shipwrecks
in wisconsin for sure we know we have
750
historic shipwreck losses
my name is caitlin zandt and i'm a
maritime archaeologist with the
wisconsin historical society
i would say the main goal of what we do
in maritime archaeology is to preserve
our maritime history and also the
history of the united states in general
the ships are quite sturdy but they've
also been underwater for
up to 150 years
our shipwrecks don't disappear over time
like they do in the oceans the fresh
water that's very cold actually does a
really good job at preserving these
shipwrecks
one of the really great things about
lake michigan that makes it really
unique is the fact that you do have
fresh clear water you can see many times
especially on deep wrecks 100 to 150
feet
when you were down there looking at a
shipwreck you start to think of all the
sailors that sailed on it or if it was a
passenger ship the passengers that
happened to be on it
you can still find pieces of
clothing in certain areas buttons shoes
and so that really gives insight to the
lives of these sailors
there's definitely a little bit of a
thrill of discovery
when we go down on a ship even on a ship
that we know we think we know what it is
there's still always that little
sense of excitement that you're going to
find something that no one else has seen
before
[Music]
you